- [Teacher] Let's say that your school
has a population of 80 students in it.
Maybe it's not your whole school.
Maybe it's just your grade.
So there's 80 students in your population
and you wanna get an estimate
of the average height
in your population and
you think it's too hard
for you to go and measure
the height of all 80 students
so you decide to find a simple
or take a simple random sample.
You think it's reasonable
for you to measure
the heights of 30 of these students
and so what you wanna
do is randomly sample
30 of the 80 students and
take their average height
and say, well, that's probably
a pretty good estimate
for the population parameter
for the average height
of the entire population.
So once you decide to do this,
you say, well, how do I
select those 30 students
and how do I select it so that I feel good
that it is actually random?
And there's several ways
that you could approach this.
One way to do it is associate
every person in your school
with a piece of paper
and put 'em all in a bowl
and then pick 'em out so let's do that.
So let's say this is alphabetically
the first person in the school.
They're on a slip of paper
then the next slip of
paper gets the next person
and you're gonna go all the way down
so you're gonna have 80 pieces of paper.
They all should be the same size
and then you throw them all,
you throw them all into
a bowl of some kind
and this seems like a
very basic way of doing it
but it's actually a pretty effective way
of getting a simple,
of getting a simple random sample.
So I'll try to draw a little,
I don't know, that looks like
a fish bowl or something.
Alright, so that's our bowl.
And so all the pieces of paper go in there
and then you put a blindfold on someone
and they can't feel what names are there
and so they should pick out the first 30
without replacing them
because you obviously
don't wanna pick the same,
you don't wanna pick
out the same name twice.
And those 30 names that you pick,
that would be your simple random sample
and then you could measure their heights
to estimate the average
height for the population.
This would be a completely
legitimate way of doing it.
Other ways that you could do it,
if you have a computer or a calculator,
you could use a random number generator
and the random functions on
computer programming languages
on your calculator, they
tend to be something,
someplace you'll see
something like a math.rand
Rand's short for random.
You might see something like random.
You might see,
you might see something like random
without anything passed into it.
It might give you a number
between zero and one
or zero and 100 and you
have to be very careful
on how you use this to
make sure that you have
an even chance of picking certain numbers
but what you would do in this situation
if you had access to some
random number generator
and it could even pick out a random number
between one and 80 including one and 80
is you would maybe line up
all the students' names alphabetically
and so the first student alphabetically
assigned the number 01
and you could just say one
if you're using a random number generator
but I'll use two digits for it
just because it'll be
useful and consistent
and in a little bit, we'll
use another technique
where it's gonna be nice to be consistent
with our number of digits.
And so the next one, 02
and you go all the way to 79
and all the way to 80
and then you use your
random number generator
to keep generating numbers from one to 80
and as long as you don't get repeats,
you pick the first 30 to be
your actual random sample.
Another related technique
which is a little bit more old school
but is definitely the way that
it has been done in the past
and even done now sometimes
is to use a random digit table.
You still start with
these number associations
with each student in the class
and then you use a randomly
generated list of numbers
and so let's say that's our
randomly generated list of numbers
and it keeps going well beyond this
and you start at the beginning
and you say, okay, we're
interested in getting,
we're interested in getting
30 two digit numbers
from one to 80 including one and 80.
So one technique that you could use
is you start right at the
beginning and you could say,
alright, this is a randomly
generated list of numbers.
So the first number here is 59.
Is 59 between one and 80?
Sure is, as long as we,
if this was a 01, that would have worked.
If this was an 80, that would have worked.
If this was a 00, it wouldn't have worked.
If this was an 81, it
wouldn't have worked.
This would be our, this right over here,
that would be our first name that we,
you could imagine the same
as picking that first name out of the hat,
whoever's associated with number 59.
Now, you would move on.
You get the next two digits.
The next two digits are 83.
They don't follow into
our range from one to 80
so we're not going to use it
then you would look at
the next two digits.
So we get a five and a nine.
Well, that fits in our range
but we already picked 59.
We already picked person 59
so we're not gonna pick 59
again so we keep moving on
then we get a 37.
Well, that's in our range,
we haven't picked that yet.
We do that then we get a 00.
Once again, not in our range.
I think you see where this is going.
91.
Not in our range.
23.
It's in our range and
we haven't picked it yet
so we're gonna pick the 23.
I think you see where this is going.
We're gonna keep going down this list
in the way that I've just
described until we get,
until we get 30 of these.
We've just gotten three.
We just have to keep on going
and this isn't an exhaustive list
of all of the different ways
that you can get random numbers
but it starts to give you some
techniques in your toolkit
and you might say, oh, well,
why don't I just randomly
come up with some numbers in my head?
And I would really suggest
that you don't do that
because humans are famously
bad at being truly random
and you might wanna do something like
even use something that you
think is a random process
but you realize later
that it wasn't as random
as you thought.
So once again, multiple techniques
but these are some of the
I would say best practices
for actually generating
a simple random sample.